so the tri-lock on tobacco took place in
this building in the council uh monday
night
uh it was quite long
almost five hours
i think we had
we had more or less agreement on most of
the issues
but we had differences on the electronic
cigarettes with the parliament
uh the good thing really which drive us
forward that we understood
that we need uh
basically to do
two things first of all electronic
cigarettes could be a tool for quitting
smoking
but also we need to avoid that these
cigarettes become a tool for as a
gateway for smoke for young smokers
so
basing
basically on this understanding we try
to find a compromised solution
which uh really to allow us
to reach an agreement as you know the
council wanted
that all electronic cigarettes would be
regulated as a pharma product
parliament
was
in an opposite
position
but when we found out basically that
what we need to do
it was an uh really a technical
elaboration of over three trilogs in a
row
on the text
how to
how to make it working
how to make it safe at the same time but
also
with a
option for member states
if they want to use farmer legislation
they can do that
well
we have agreed with the parliament on
monday night
preliminary and today was a
was let's say a major day
that agreement had to be uh ratified by
the corrupter
the meeting
was i'd say joyful for the presidency
because uh
we had almost unanimous support in the
council only one member state voting
against
and uh that's it uh now the uh this is
uh procedural technical things at some
point uh
parliament will vote in the in the
plenary the council will approve the
text and it will become a law
sometime end of the year next year